well I'm freakin great except I have one
qualms with the world oh I want the
crazy rich Asians cast out the Oscars oh
that would be amazing John Chu had said
that on his on his Twitter get the whole
cast I think it's an amazing idea that
would be really dope we've had all this
controversy you guys would bring the
lightness to it I was it felt to be at
all these award shows together and the
movie to get so much acclaim it's a gift
that keeps on giving it is one of those
things where I've been blessed to be a
part of some amazing projects and crazy
rich Asians is right at the top because
no one knew that this movie would be as
commercially successful as it is we
always we all knew would be a great
movie but to have not only that
financial impact but a cultural impact
I've never been a part of anything of
any movie you know on those levels as
special as this we're asking us for a
Valentine's Day piece I know how much
you love your amazing wife how did you
guys first meet we met at work I was a
doctor she's a doctor and we were kind
of like the other couple in When Harry
Met Sally
we're like Bruno Kirby and Carrie Fisher
like we had broken up with our
respective mates and they we're
literally commiserating at like a happy
hour then we just got together months
later we got engaged it's kind of crazy
love story yeah now we're obsessed with
the masked singer yeah I mean how do you
feel about the way it's taken off I
again another beyond shock no one knew
no one knew I mean we knew it would be
it would just be like a wickedly fun
show but it's insane it's in a great way
[Music]